>> Laura: I LEARNED ABOUT THIS
OVER THE WEEKEND, AND I WAS JUST
INFURIATED.
AN 11-YEAR-OLD GIRL WAS TOLD SHE
HAD TO WRITE A REPORT ON HER
HERO.
SHE QUICKLY CHOSE PRESIDENT
TRUMP, PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, SOMEONE SHE HAS ADMIRED
SINCE THIRD GRADE.
BUT HER TEACHER SAYS NO.
SHAMED HER IN FRONT OF OTHER
STUDENTS AND WARNED BELLA TO
CHOOSE A DIFFERENT HERO.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
SUPERINTENDENT TELLING "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" --
BELLA'S PARENTS JOIN ME NOW
VALUE
>> WHEN SHE FOUND OUT THAT TRUMP
WAS HER HERO, SHE SAID, YOU'RE
NOT ALLOWED TO PICK TRUMP.
HE SPREADS NEGATIVITY AND HE
SAYS BAD THINGS ABOUT WOMEN.
AND I WAS LIKE # FLOORED WHEN I
HEARD THAT.
>> Laura: WELL, FOR A LITTLE
GIRL TO HAVE THE POISE TO NOT
JUST BUCKLE UNDER THE PRESSURE
AND ACTUALLY COME HOME AND SAY,
MOM, DAD, THIS DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT, THAT'S WHAT ACTUALLY
GIVES ME A LOT OF HOPE, IS THAT
YOUR LITTLE GIRL SAID, NO, I'M
NOT GIVING IN.
THAT'S PRETTY UNUSUAL, I HAVE TO
SAY.
>> WELL, I'M GOING TO SAY THIS
TO YOU.
MY DAUGHTER CALLED MY WIFE
DURING THE SCHOOL DAY TO LET MY
WIFE KNOW THAT.
AND THE UPSETTING THING TO ME,
WHICH I ACTUALLY FOUND OUT
LATER, WAS THAT NOT ONLY WAS MY
DAUGHTER TOLD THAT SHE COULDN'T
DO THAT, BUT SHE HAD TO GO
AROUND AND PICK SOMEBODY ELSE AS
HER HERO.
WHEN MY DAUGHTER SPOKE TO MY
WIFE -- YES, SOMEBODY ELSE'S
HERO.
>> YEAH, GO AROUND AND CHOOSE --
>> Laura: AND DIDN'T SOMEBODY IN
THE CLASS ALSO PICK OBAMA AND
THAT WAS OKAY?
>> YEAH.
>> APPARENTLY, YEAH, MM-HM.
>> Laura: NATURALLY, THAT'S A
SHOCK.
>> SO, MY OUTBURST AT THE BOARD
OF ED MEETING HAD A LOT TO DO
WITH THAT BECAUSE --
>> Laura: ARE YOU BOTH SATISFIED
-- SORRY TO INTERRUPT, BUT ARE
YOU BOTH SATISFIED WITH THE
SCHOOL'S RESPONSE HERE?
I TWEETED OUT YOUR REACTION.
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
WHAT DO YOU WANT FROM THE
SCHOOL?
THEY SEEM A SOMEWHAT APOLOGETIC.
>> I'M JUST GOING TO SAY.
THE MESSAGE THAT YOU JUST
PLAYED, MY WIFE AND I HAVE NEVER
HEARD.
>> YEAH.
>> NOW, LISTEN, WE LOVE OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT
WITHIN THERE.
MY DAUGHTER IS ONE OF FOUR KIDS.
WE HAVE THREE BOYS ALSO.
THE SCHOOL -- WE'VE ALWAYS HAD
VERY GOOD EXPERIENCES.
AND THIS ONE IS A LITTLE SOUR.
>> Laura: VALERIE, HOW IMPORTANT
DO YOU THINK IT IS FOR PARENTS
TO SPEAK OUT WHEN THIS KIND OF
STUFF HAPPENS?
BECAUSE IT HAPPENINGSE
BECAUSE ITSHAPPENINGSE
BECAUSE ITS APPENINGSE
BECAUSE ITS  HPENINGSE
BECAUSE ITS  HAPNINGSE
BECAUSE ITS  HAPPENGSE
BECAUSE ITS  HAPPENSSE
BECAUSE ITS  HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME.
>> I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL AND HAPPY
THAT THIS STORY HAS GOTTEN AS
BIG AS IT HAS BECAUSE THIS STORY
NEEDS TO BE TOLD.
AND I'M VERY PROUD THAT MY
DAUGHTER KNEW THAT THAT WAS
WRONG AND CALLED ME DURING THE
SCHOOL TO TELL ME THIS BECAUSE,
LET ME TELL YOU, LAURA --
>> Laura: YOU TAUGHT HER.
>> RIGHT.
AND IF SHE DIDN'T TELL ME THIS,
SHE WASN'T DOING TRUMP.
SHE'S ABLE TO DO TRUMP BECAUSE
OF ME AND MY HUSBAND, NOT
BECAUSE OF THE SCHOOL, THE
DISTRICT, OR THE DISTRICT.
BECAUSE WE RAISED HOLY HELL
ABOUT IT.
AND THIS IS AN IN-SCHOOL
PROJECT.
>> Laura: WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO
GET THE TEACHER ON THE SHOW AND
SEE WHAT SHE SAYS NOW THAT SHE
MAYBE HAS HAD TIME TO REFLECT ON
IT AND WE'LL CHECK BACK WITH YOU